- I have never read Playboy before.
- 'Cause I grew up in the digital age,
so you didn't really need magazines.
- I just want to apologize to my mom.
I feel like I'm sinning.
- [Voiceover] The 1960's.
- I'm more aroused by
the prices back then.
Twenty-five cents for everything.
- Like, the old school art
is so vintage, so cool.
I don't see any boobs yet.
- Do people actually read the articles?
- There are a lot of articles.
I feel like that was the old joke.
- The moment of truth, I
always wanted to do this.
- Daaamn.
- Oh, I feel so raunchy.
- That is just an
American Apparel ad today.
- [Voiceover] Uh-oh, eighties.
- I'm expecting hair on hair on hair.
- The first bush era.
- Every picture kind of looks
like a Prince album cover.
- I know women at Walmart
that are from the eighties
'cause they still have
their hair like this
and they can't let it go.
- They're too poofy, they look
like Pomeranians got naked.
(whipping sound)
- It's like a Glamour Shot.
It looks like something
you would take at the mall.
- That is a jungle.
- In the sixties they were
kinda like, ooh, what's there,
but in the eighties they
were just like boom!
Take a good look, America.
- [Voiceover] So, this is the nineties.
- I'm just playing the
theme from Full House
in my head as I'm looking through this.
- The nineties ones just look
like my teacher, it's weird.
- It comes with a bio.
- It has her childhood photos.
How do you go to your
parents, like, "Hey Dad,
"I need some pictures of my childhood
"because I'm kind of in Playboy?"
- This is not up to health code.
Don't eat this popcorn.
- [Voiceover] The 2000s.
- This is like when Playboy needed
to step their game up, 'cause
the internet was around,
and people could get it for free.
- Just drunk college girls lifting
their shirts up to the camera.
That was a thing for
like a decade and a half.
- And now I'm seeing an article
about the two faces of Islam.
- Good boxing theme,
'cause she's a knockout.
- She's a racecar driver.
Well, she's a girl who sits on racecars.
- This is when Photoshop
started to come in.
She's way too smooth-looking.
- I feel like you painted her body.
This is not real, this is not real.
- [Voiceover] 2015.
- Country girls.
- My family has a farm, so
I sort of grew up on there.
No one dresses like
this when they're like,
"I'm gonna go drive the tractor".
- If they wanna sell these,
they should do hipster
girls of Silver Lake.
- These girls are imported.
- None of these girls have
ever been to the South.
- Although, we did have tire swings.
- There's not a whole
lot of racial diversity
in these Playboys, and
I'm kind of upset by that.
Brown people can be in
the country too, you know.
- There's water everywhere.
They don't know how to
drink out of a canteen.
- This part is sexy
but then like this part
where it's just dripping off
at the end, you're like, ew.
- As the time went on, it was getting just
more explicit and less tasteful.
- Not gonna read 'em, I don't think,
just 'cause, I mean, the internet.
- Just interesting with
these old magazines.
You and your friends
all looked at the same
two dozen naughty pictures.
- I guess it's more like
a recognizable name.
It's like McDonalds but for naked people.
- Just want to apologize to my mom again.
I'm sorry, this is weird.
I know this is weird for both of us
'cause you're gonna watch this.